n'ouvrons ce journal avec la fracassante
déclaration de bernard bonnet après deux
mois de détention provisoire
l'ex préfet de corse qui est sorti en
fin d'après midi de la prison de la
santé s'est dit victime d'un véritable
complot judiciaire des mots qui se
veulent incisif mordant accusateurs et
notamment à l'égard du ministre de la
justice michèle fils guillaume faudra
lors de nadaillac l'ex préfet de corse a
quitté sa prison sans se cacher et
devant toute la presse
les premiers mots ont été soigneusement
pesé
je suis très profondément irrité de la
situation que j'ai vécu
j'affirme avoir été victime d'un complot
judiciaire pour être plus précis
un attentat judiciaire corse commis en
bande organisée
les auteurs de cet attentat ont volé
deux mois de ma vie je trouve
inacceptable
une ministre de la république madame
guigou puisse bafouer
avec une telle imprudence le principe de
la présomption d'innocence par les
déclarations qu'elle a faites au club de
la presse rock numéro un
je considère que de telles déclarations
sont une défaillance
je peux vous annoncer quelques quelques
coups de théâtre à brève échéance
l' affaire commence
libre bernard bonnet et placé sous
contrôle judiciaire il est assigné à
résidence en ile de france et doit
pointer une fois par semaine au
commissariat
le préfet n'a pas le droit de
communiquer avec les gendarmes impliqués
dans la sphère des paillotes ni avec les
témoins son premier geste d'hommes
libres
une pause café dans ce bar du 7e
arrondissement avec sa fille anne laure
et son fils d phase extraordinaire
sentiment de liberté
quelque chose qui n'existe pas en prison
on veut tous émus les sofas liberté
et puis en fin d'après-midi le préfet
bonnet rentrer chez lui enfin
accompagner encore par de très nombreux
journalistes
je ne me suis jamais senti en relation
des faits le préfet bonnet a fini par
permet la porte au journal y mais ce
n'est que provisoirement